foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
if you think maybe he wanted to be
indicted
[Music]
I mean I don't know I mean if you're
taking advice from Cracker Jack
non-attorney like Tom Vinton
that's [__] snowflake
so uh obviously we know that Tom Vinton
has given Donald Trump advice
advice
legal counsel even though Thompson isn't
an attorney
he he's he's not one
he it Trump hey dude Grandpa
Tom Fenton not only is he not an
attorney he's not a smart person either
like he's a dumb [__]
so the story is this
Donald Trump stole our government's
documents our documents he stole them he
took them to Mar-A-Lago they figured out
that he stole these documents and the
Nara said hey
the National Archives said hey dude
Grandpa we want our documents back we
want our [__] back and Grandpa's like no
not gonna give him back
and like no no no seriously we we want
him back he's like nope no they're mine
they're all mine it's all my documents
and they're like no
they're not your documents so Trump's
attorney is like his real attorney
Corcoran his real attorney like the real
attorney the one with a license right
Corcoran says dude you know what we can
do we could like go to the government
and negotiate a deal where we just give
back their [__] and everything's cool
you keep your personal documents
and they get their documents back like
that that would be that that's thing
that we could do
and there would be no trouble and
they're going to give you leniency
because you're a former president just
like they've given other former
presidents other former secretaries
estate other cabinet members uh other
vice presidents other Senators leeway
when they're like hey we want our [__]
back
you you probably inadvertently took it
that's what we're guessing we're giving
you the benefit of the doubt
and doj's like yeah we really don't want
to prosecute a former president
but Donald Trump and Tom Fenton
are are sitting around eating Big Macs
I'm assuming
Tom Fenton and his little sister's shirt
and Donald Trump in his [__] circus
tent that is a suit
they're sitting around talking about how
he's gonna get away with crime I guess I
don't know the [__] I mean here's the
thing
are we supposed to believe that Tom
Fenton is so convincing
with his non-lawyer
degree and his non-law license and his
buffoonery and his dumb [__]
that he's more convincing than an actual
attorney are we supposed to believe that
or are we supposed to believe
that Donald Trump listens to Tom Fenton
because Tom Fenton says exactly what
Trump wants to hear
that's what it is right
that's what it has to be man it can't be
anything other than that right am I
[__] wrong
it it's a situation where there's
cognitive dissonance
but Trump is looking
for every
single way that he can to make sure
that his stupid ass opinion becomes
reality
which it doesn't matter what Tom Benton
says doesn't [__] matter like it
doesn't matter it doesn't even matter
what Corcoran said to be quite honest I
mean Corcoran was just trying to get
Trump to do a deal because Corcoran
probably thought that was the best bet
for Donald Trump to get out of this
unscathed without hardly any press at
all
before there was a raid a raid on
Mar-A-Lago
which was a legal search warrant to get
the documents back that he refused to
give and was obstructing not only that
he was hiding them and then lying about
having them and or not having them
whichever you want to see it as
and Tom Fenton was willing to sit there
and go yeah yeah that's right that's the
law wink
so let me tell you a little story about
Tom Benton Tom Fenton hates my guts he
hates my e8s Gabe Sanchez's guts too
almost as much as Seb Gorka hates
whoever this is with the last name
Sanchez
whoever that guy is with the last name
Sanchez Seb Gorka hates him but Tom
Fenton I believe may may dislike
Gabe a little more than Seb I'm not
really sure I guess we can smoke that
out when Gabe gets on air
but Tom Fenton hates me he blocked me we
were in a Twitter space one time and Tom
Fenton was talking all kinds of [__]
nonsense just stupid ass ridiculous
[__] nonsense in this Twitter space
saying [__] that doesn't even doesn't
even hold water
um here it was the this was When Donald
Trump
was being indicted in New York
okay this is the first arraignment the
first set of felonies that this guy is
charged with and indicted by a grand
jury okay the first set of them not this
last set okay
I wonder if he listened to Tom Fenton on
those charges too probably oh
so we're in this space and Tom Fenton
says two different things at the same
time right he makes two different
arguments
two arguments the argument is that
charging a former president of the
United States with felonies because it's
a political Witch Hunt will destroy our
country that's the one argument that
they had that day in the space right you
still hear this stupid [__] which it I
mean I it's our democracy crumbled yet
hey someone get on the phone and call
the democracy and see if it's crumbled
yet it hasn't
[__] idiots
just because you indict a former
president doesn't mean your democracy is
going to crumble really honestly it
makes it stronger that's the argument
that I would like to make but here was
their other argument
is that this is going to guarantee that
Donald Trump becomes president I'm like
okay so and I got into space I said Tom
I want you to keep going because Tom Tom
Fenton and Seb Gorka were in the space
at the same time saying that stupid [__]
making these two arguments and I said
you dumb [__] sound dumber than
dog [__] when you say it's gonna destroy
our country and guarantee that Donald
Trump is President so which is it is it
going to guarantee that he's the
president and then it's going to go to
[__] well I mean you're uh what explain
to me you're two different [__]
arguments because you claim to believe
that Donald Trump will save our country
but and if this is going to guarantee he
wins then how's it going to destroy our
democracy maybe maybe just maybe what
you're saying is Donald Trump wants to
destroy the Democracy it really [__]
pissed Seb and Tom off oh they were mad
they blocked me for it I guess because
they're [__] [__] ass [__]
they're [__] they're [__] fascist
snowflake six
they are these nincompoop Nazis aren't
anything but weak weak pieces of dumb
dog [__] like I said just like Tom
Benton and these are the clowns that
Trump is listening to
Tom Fenton is the guy now here's the
reason why Tom Fenton hates the guy with
the last name Sanchez
the reason why the reason why Fenton
hates Gabe
is because Gabe asked him in a space he
just asked him he said aren't you the
guy who told Donald Trump before the
election to make sure to on the night of
the election to claim you want even
though you're not winning and that it's
all rigged against you aren't you that
guy
Tom Fenton is that guy so not only is
Donald Trump
more than likely
gonna be indicted
on who [__] it could be over a hundred
[__] felonies at this point God knows
how many [__] counts he's gonna catch
in Georgia who [__] knows how many
counts he's gonna catch in DC over
January 6th if the Georgia case works
out folks there could be charges in
Arizona Michigan Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin over the fake elector scheme
eventually so no ma no no Talon how many
thousands of years that this guy's gonna
face in a [__] jail cell because he's
listening to Tom Fenton
so listen to me when I tell you this
Tom baby keep giving this [__]
advice I want Tom Fenton to be his head
lawyer his [__] his [__] campaign
manager and his and his and his goddamn
PR person [__] yeah let's do that let's
make Tom the top of the chain let's make
him at the top of the totem pole man
because if you guys think that there's
not a Shining Light here that this
[__] buffoon Grandpa poopy pants the
Cheeto dust q and honor is listening to
the dumbest [__] non-lawyer in this
country if you don't see the Silver
Lining that is catching him in federal
case after federal case State case after
State case and we're talking dozens
dozens of felonies because he won't
listen to a real [__] lawyer but
he'll listen to Tom Vinton because Tom
Finn tells him what the [__] he wants to
hear keep going [__] keep going
keep doing that man don't stop listening
to Tom Fenton and I told this to Tom and
this is what really [__] got
underneath his his [__] little shirt
skin right you can really see everything
about Tom Fenton because he wears a
shirt that's like six sizes too [__]
small you ever notice that Jesus Christ
dude
I mean there's fitted dress shirts but
man man the buttons are hanging on for
dear life Tom Jesus Christ in a shirt
that fits man
but here's the thing here's the thing
that pissed him off the most because I
told him Tom I said Tom keep going buddy
keep going keep doing what you're doing
you're gonna destroy Donald Trump and
you're gonna destroy trumpism
in this country and that's fantastic
you're gonna get all kinds of people out
there who don't pay attention to
politics
to to absolutely look at your arguments
and go you're dumb as [__] and that's
stupid and Trump is an idiot for
listening to you so thank you Tom Finn
that's what I want to say today thank
you Tom Vinton thank you so much uh for
your advice to Donald Trump and for your
capitulation and your cognitive
dissonance and your [__] stupid legal
takes I'm excited about Tom Fenton's
legal takes it's fantastic fantastic
keep going [__]
oh my God
oh
I don't I don't know why anyone would be
upset about this
like why are you upset that Donald
Trump's going to destroy himself
by listening to a hack
like Thompson and and I know Trump
really probably truly does believe that
Tom Benton is a [__] genius right
because Tom Fenton is the same as like
all these Elon scents who think Elon is
a [__] genius like oh my God come on
man
I mean it's it's he is he is and you see
it all the time in these spaces with Doc
there was this Leo guy in the last space
claimed to be a constitutional lawyer I
don't know if he was or not he was
making stupid [__] arguments and some
people in the space like well that
sounds like a legitimate argument like
no it's not it's not read the indictment
it's not a legitimate argument they're
just running in circles about how if he
could declassify them or not it doesn't
[__] matter this case this indictment
in Florida
has nothing to do nothing to do with the
presidential records act they don't
claim
they do not claim
that he broke the law
with the presidential records act they
claim he broke the law
with the Espionage Act you [__]
idiots now let me give you a little
history on the Espionage Act I believe
the Espionage Act was
um all the way back in 1917. did you
know
that there was a presidential candidate
who was imprisoned
for breaking the Espeon Espionage Act in
1920 who ran for president from prison
how [__] exciting is that
how exciting is that is that there was a
time in this country where someone broke
the Espionage Act and ran for president
from inside a prison cell did you know
that [__] that's [__] real I'm not
lying I wouldn't lie to you I wouldn't
[__] you you're my favorite turd of
course this this is real
there was a actual presidential
candidate who broke the Espionage Act
and was imprisoned and ran from prison
in this country so this idea that
somehow this is the worst Hub I guess
most agrees this is political this is
all political and it's going to destroy
our country
you don't have to look very far
just about a hundred years back you can
find that our country survived that and
really honestly in that case it was a
lot more political than this one
they were actually suppressed
suppressing him with speech
this candidate was was uh talking about
anti-war
uh he was doing anti-war speech what
they used then they used the Espionage
Act
to do it Eugene Debs John John brings up
his name in 1920. see I'm not making
this [__] up
I'm not making this up I don't have to
make [__] up here on the Tony Michaels
podcast
I don't have to do that
so there was a time in this country
where they used the Espionage Act to
imprison candidates and we survived
dummies
Maga just they just don't want they just
don't want to know the truth just like
Donald Trump didn't want to know the
truth and the truth was hey man you
can't keep these documents to try to
sell the Saudi Arabia
you can't do it you can't try to keep
these documents to hold it over the head
of people because they're not yours
the government's documents are the
government's documents and you keep
yelling and screaming the presidential
records act because I know that's what
Tom Fenton is telling you
but the presidential director's Acts
says the opposite of what you're saying
the presidential record to act
defines what is a personal record and
what is a government record it's
specifically
defines what they are and the [__]
Clinton sock drawer thing you boneheads
the reason why Clinton wasn't found
guilty of anything or charged is because
the tapes that he had were personal
Diaries
and the presidential records act laid
out and they went to court over this
lays out that those pieces of documents
which were recordings of Bill Clinton
for his personal biography
were his they were his personal
recordings it was like a personal diary
right
because he was making the recording it
was like a recorded diary
that's the [__] but they like the sock
drawer thing oh yeah because it's so
salacious the sack drawer
dude it was it was just recordings he
was just making audio recordings of like
a diary so that he had the ability to
remember and write a book and have
someone help him write a book and the
best way to do that anyone anyone who's
a writer out there a Ghostwriter out
there would know that it would be
someone dictating their diary or writing
it down Bill Clinton preferred to
dictate it and do a recorder dummy
that's what that was this soccer thing
they act like he had classified
documents inside the soccer or no you
had classified documents spread all over
the place you [__] idiot
and they knew you did and you wouldn't
give them back and then you lied about
the ones that you that you didn't give
back you said you didn't have them oh
there you got them nope nope
moving around playing musical classified
documents with them from the bathroom to
the storage room to the stage to the
pool room the [__] out of here with this
nonsense
it's crime man you broke the Espionage
Act not the presidential records act the
presidential records act actually what
it does and I hope I hope that Tom
Fenton convinces you to use this
argument in open court when you go to
trial after this next election grandpa I
hope he conventures you to use the
argument that they that we should hash
out the presidential records act because
the presidential records Act is going to
show in open court during your criminal
trial [__] that the records you
were hiding weren't yours so keep going
keep doing it man I'm not going to take
the shovel out of your hand while you're
digging your [__] political grave
I I matter of fact I want to hand you a
backhoe if we could create three or four
more Tom Fentons to get into the ear of
Donald Trump fan fuckin-tastic
they can't stop stepping on rakes it's
great
frankly their stupidity and their dumb
[__] may just save our democracy in
and of itself
yeah the idea that Donald Trump was
paying legal counsel real legal counsel
to give him advice to undo the stupid
[__] that he did when he took these
documents
and was not storing them properly was
not keeping them secure properly
that that an actual group of attorneys
was trying to make sure that they could
do a deal to get these documents back
where Donald Trump would not suffer any
consequences whatsoever
even even consequences in the open
public because it's likely that Nara and
the doj would have done this deal and
kept it under seal and it would be years
before we'd find out about this
years but he chose not to and then when
[__] hit the fan and they went to get
their [__] documents with the goddamn
search warrant
Donald Trump is the one who told us
about it
and he continued to tell us about the
case every time I almost bet every time
his lawyers came back and give him news
from the special counsel's office or the
doj or from the courts
and any sealed Court meeting they had I
guaran damned T the first thing he did
was start telling everyone that he was
around including Tom Fenton
he would probably call Tom Fenton on the
phone and tell him this [__] and try to
see what Tom if Tom Benton would tell
him what he wanted to hear and I
guarantee you that's probably what
happened
and every time Donald Trump took Tom
Fenton's [__] Cracker Jack advice
because Tom Fenton I don't mean to
insult Cracker Jacks to be quite honest
[__] I'm sorry Cracker Jacks I don't
want to get canceled here
who
today for insulting Cracker Jacks by
comparing Tom Fenton to them oh [__]
but taking Tom Fenton's Cracker Jack
advice every single time and I couldn't
tell you how excited I am that he's
going to continue to do it
why wouldn't why would he stop now
why I again
[__]
he he probably would have Tom Fenton
defending him if Tom Finn was an actual
[__] lawyer
which he's not not even close
not easy not easy not only a lawyer he's
not a lawyer he's an idiot
his legal advice is shittier than Alina
Havas yeah and Christina Bob that's a
low [__] bar folks when your legal
advice is shittier than Christina Bob
and Alina Heather baby you have reached
an all-time low
yeah so when they tell you that this is
unpristing oh my God I can't believe
they're gonna charge a president of the
United States during an election and
they're going to try to make sure that
he can't run for president that's all
[__] we've been through this before
1920. there was a candidate who ran for
president inside a jail cell that's
right and he was charged under the
Espionage Act
that's the [__] truth and we're still
here today our democracy is still here
so I can yell and scream into a
microphone as I do every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube don't
forget to subscribe if you're on YouTube
right now don't forget to hit that
subscribe button we're so close to 16
000. we're so close yeah I mean we
should be at like 160 000 by now
subscribers on YouTube but we're at
we're at 15
960. I need 40 more subscribers to get
the 16. we really should be at 20 40 50.
I mean this show is the best political
Show on Earth
I I just [__] doubt me to try it I'm
gonna show you some [__] today that you
won't believe
that the audiences helped produce we got
the best audience in the [__] world
here at the Tony Michaels podcast and
it's only because this show is an
outlier
there's no show like this I challenge
you to go find a show that is set up
like this not one not one this is it
this is it and you got to come here
every single day and you might as well
download
every single episode do us a favor
download it on Apple Spotify and Google
it puts us up in the rankings when you
download it on those directories and
it's free it doesn't cost you a single
nickel to download it just like it
doesn't cost you a single nickel to
watch it
this show is free free 99 five finger
discount you can watch it on Facebook
even at the Tony Michaels follow us on
Facebook if you still have a Facebook
account there's also another YouTube
channel you can watch it on it's the up
wire go to the upwire.com follow their
Channel over there as well or go to the
just go to YouTube and search the up
wire you'll find the channel there to
follow and follow us on Twitch
the chat over on Twitch is always lit
that's right over on Twitch and we want
to thank everyone
who the links there's Amazon Prime
account to their Twitch account and
gives us that one free subscription you
get
with your Amazon Prime account every
single month then you have to renew it
you have to resub and I want to thank
everyone who resubs and we've got people
who have been resubbing over there on
Twitch for five or six months so thank
you very much for all the support on
Twitch and it doesn't cost you anything
to follow us on Twitch so if you don't
have a Prime account no problem you can
still go to Twitch you can still follow
us you can still get in the chat
over there
on Twitch
I got some good video to show you
there's a remix of a song
[Laughter]
at one of our one of our great audience
members has made there's a remix and
it's got said Gorka in it and the great
the great Gabe Sanchez who is this guy
with the last name
Sanchez I don't know we'll figure it out
when we come back right after this break
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with these
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
bumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
it's Thursday you know what Thursday is
we vote tonight
on bonehead of the week
and I can almost bet he wins already
right
oh man
I can't tell you how excited it makes me
um when someone like Tom Fenton is the
is the steering steering guide for
Donald Trump in his legal woes I'm dead
serious That's The Shining Light in all
of this like a lot of people always like
what the [__] oh my God I was like this
is great
do you know how excited it makes me that
Tom Fenton is in Donald Trump's ear
telling him what to do
that's fantastic
keep on going buddy don't stop man
I mean Tom Fenton is going to be
responsible for Trump spending decades
in prison how do you not see that as a
bright side of this right
like yeah is it kind of [__] up that a
former president United States who had
the [__] nuclear codes is listening
to legal advice from someone like Tom
Benton who has been wrong time and time
and time again think about that
think about it he's been wrong with
Donald Trump
that has caused Donald Trump all kinds
of [__] legal problems
and he still listens to him
you don't see that as a good thing here
politically I mean the writes always
like oh there's no political this is a
political prosecution it's all political
yeah so
and
what's the problem
what's what's the problem yeah of course
of course it's political Donald Trump's
running for president speaking of people
who's running for president uh Rhonda
santis this morning
um was in front of a lackluster crowd
talking this morning and um
he really wants Gavin Newsom to get in
the race
Ron dude Ron
someone's saying it's fitting Fenton I
don't give a [__] I'll say it wrong if I
want to
it's Tom Fenton listen Rhonda Santos was
in front of a stage this morning talking
about how he wants Gavin Newsom to get
in the race to challenge Joe Biden now
the problem is is that Rhonda Santos
hasn't listened to Gavin Newsom at all
almost like some of the people on the
left haven't listened to Gavin Newsom
I've heard this [__] Gavin needs to get
in he needs to challenge Biden are you
listening to what Gavin Newsom is saying
Gavin Newsom is saying we need to elect
Joe Biden because Joe Biden is a very
effective president is what that's Gavin
newsom's case
folks
that's that's how what that's what he is
stumping for is Joe Biden
Gavin Newsom knows he can't [__] beat
Joe Biden
Gavin Newsom knows that
it's a thing now what Rhonda santis
wants is because Gavin newsom's talks
some good [__] I mean he destroys
DeSantis right
destroys him
and that's what got that's what got old
pudding fingers all upset got his
meatball undies in a bunch right is that
Gavin Newsom flung some [__] towards his
Direction because he deserves it Rhonda
Santos is a piece of fascist [__]
he's a fascist in Android and a human
skin suit it's even real is Rhonda
Santos real is he a real human is he I
don't know it's [__] weird if he is
he's a weird [__] if he is
Governor weirdo down there in Florida
but that's the thing Ron listen man
you're in the wrong race on the wrong
year okay Gavin Newsom is likely going
to run in 2028. he knows that
he knows that why do you think he's
stumping for Joe Biden and he's doing
such a damn good job of it
like on the hand of the interview the
reason why is because not only is he
trying to get Joe Biden to win
but he's trying to be the predecessor of
Joe Biden here
that's what he's trying to do
[Laughter]
come on man
come on you don't see that you're in the
wrong race you should have waited I told
you this I said this Ron I I tried to
get it through your meatball thick head
but you won't listen to me
it's dumb you should maybe you're
listening to Tom Fenton too [__] I don't
know
but the thing is is with Rhonda santis
if he would have just stayed out of this
race and just remained governor
what he could have done was run in 2028
without damaging his political career
and without Trump absolutely [__]
burning him down and pissing on the
ashes [__] he may have even got Trump to
endorse him from a prison cell you know
what I mean
it's possible I don't know
but if he really wanted to run against
Gavin Newsom man you should have waited
what why were you so hell-bent on being
president now I mean you'll never be
president because you're [__] weirdo
but why were you so hell-bent on it now
why can you wait four years man
huh are you are you scared that wokeism
is gonna take over the country and you
won't have a way to sell your fascism is
that what you're scared of Iran
that you couldn't wait for 2028 that the
culture wars was already won by the woke
you know like common sense and I mean
that's it's the culture wars are over
Ron and Common Sense One Liberty one
Equity diversity equality one sorry I
know you want to try to turn back the
clock
it's just not where it's not what we're
gonna do in this country you may try it
down in Florida but we're not going to
do it in the rest of the country they
don't like your we'll go broke thing
okay
your wokey little [__] speeches that
you give man
but Ronda Santos this morning is begging
begging
begging that Gavin do some getting in
the race and again I don't understand
why if you want Gavin Newsom in a race
then you should have waited
everyone knows that anyone with a
[__] brain anyone who knows how
elections work knows how primaries work
know how our two political parties work
anyone who knows this would know that
gavinusum is likely going to run in the
primary in 2028 he was never going to do
it in 2024. I told you that months ago
people are saying gay avenuesome needs
to run against Biden I said no he's not
going to
he won't okay he won't do it
because he's not stupid Gavin Newsom is
not a [__]
he knows how his party Works he knows
how primaries work he knows how
elections work he knows that the
incumbent is the nominee no matter what
and then you have you have pieces of
garbage like teen Nina Turner that's
right I'm gonna go after and I'm gonna
go after tyt so if you hear in your tyt
sim
put your seat belt on you're not gonna
like the next little diatribe that I
have but I'm gonna do it I don't give a
[__]
because tyt is trash it is grifter trash
they're lying to you Nina Turner tweets
out something about a third-party
candidate
that America knows they want a third
party because we can do better than
Trump
DeSantis or Biden listen you dumb
[__] that's not true tell me
show me show me evidence here's the
evidence that you need to show me that a
third party candidate has ever in the
history of ever ever
had a chance
in the general election of a
presidential
General
election in this country show me where a
third party has garnished enough vote
that would go oh yeah looks like the
country wants them the country never
wants a third party dummy
there's no and it really is Rich coming
from Nina Turner who is lost like I
don't know what two or three times
in a congressional race in Ohio get the
[__] out of here man
it go sell your garbage someplace else
[__] talking about Marianne
Williamson RFK and get the [__] out of
here a third party the [__] out of here
this nonsense
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize that what this country knows and
what it doesn't know Jesus Christ they
vote on affiliation anyways
I don't know if this guy's gonna vote
third party I highly doubt it but did
you see Nina Turner's tweet Gabe Sanchez
did you see her tweet
Nina Turner yeah no I don't focus on her
too much yeah she's a bonehead gee I
mean I see her stuff occasionally oh my
god it feels like you don't have the
right mic on oh sorry there you hear me
now yeah it was on to the side oh much
better much better when you talk into it
this [__] guy
who is this guy with the last name
Sanchez isn't it great this morning that
we find out that Trump has been
listening to Tom Fenton this whole time
tell the audience tell the audience how
you pissed him off because I told him
how I pissed him off yeah yeah you
pissed Fenton off because he blocked
both of us and said you know you love
said but Seb doesn't like you yeah but I
love you Seb so this is this is how uh
this is how I play the remix I know
everyone's out there wants to hear the
remix is great I listened to this
morning yeah Sanchez I had him as soon
as I woke up I was like I had a plan
small right here can someone ran here
today someone would bring small rat to
the stage can someone bring small rats
here please
[Music]
so the way that I pissed off Tom Finn
was um I had a couple tweets that were
like
he he tweeted something and I quote
tweeted and I was like dude you're the
guy who emailed because everyone should
should always Hammer this one home Tom
fitton emailed the White House and told
them you know as his Judicial Watch or
whatever said there was an election and
we won this is also a letter that was
that was shown in the January 6 coverage
that Tony and I did
um by the way small rat is here so small
rat I just want to say make sure you
stick around we're going to show you so
so basically uh it's funny how all these
people like the irony of all these
people who are like oh censorship is bad
and then they just completely block you
which again totally you're right but if
you're gonna say if you're gonna say
that censorship is bad do not censor
people who are an opposing view
especially those who call you out with
so what happened was they don't like
facts do they I keep telling you this I
keep saying Gabe you gotta stop with the
facts they can't help it I got I don't
like that stuff they don't like that
kind of stuff it really [__] with them
look their brains
I got this i got this Condition it's a
it's a facts disorder oh really yeah and
it's it's sometimes it's real bad
because like I'll be in a situation and
I can't stop saying facts you know what
there's I think there's a new I was
watching a commercial the other day
there's a new um there's a new drug out
there that that helps you have more
cognitive dissonance maybe maybe we'll
maybe we'll show that here in a minute
yeah yeah I would love to see it yeah
I'll see if I can dig up that commercial
to see if we can find it
um so so so basically we were in a
Twitter space in one of Mario's Twitter
spaces and uh I previously made fun of
Tom Finn you know and I also I'm gonna
do what was that on this uh I took a
break last week because I was like
there's so much [__] going on uh but I'm
gonna do what was that on this for sure
because
it's hilarious how Tom Finn will go into
these spaces and be like Oh I'm a I'm an
expert law mind and it's like no no
you're an English major you're not a
lawyer you could never really hack it so
don't try to don't try to bring up this
whole idea that you created a a legal uh
Think Tank organization and that you can
be like we have over 30 years of legal
experience
no you don't you don't have it your
organization may be your organization
hires lawyers yeah you hire lawyers not
you because you're not one but you have
to hire lawyers because you're not one
and then you're the talking head of this
organization and then so so basically
multiple times I made fun of uh on one
of the Twitter spaces I made fun of Tom
fitton wearing shirts that are two sizes
too small right
what did you say did you say it to him
yeah yeah I was like Tom Finn's on here
this guy wears shirts that are two sizes
too small don't worry I got all these
jokes
you said that out loud we gotta find
that one [__] yeah but that was like I
feel like it was like months ago when he
was in there yeah well but it was
because he stopped coming on because
um uh will will [__] text him in the
middle of one right and Tom Vinton lost
his mind reason he got mad was because
Tom fitton called will legate a Marxist
yeah and
will the gate texted uh Tom fitton and
personal self not a Marxist I own my own
company
and then Tom fayden was on the Twitter
face he goes who just texted me from
this number and he goes I did it's me
you made a claim that I was a Marxist
and I was texting you to tell you that I
wasn't and Tom Fenton was freaking he's
like I'm not gonna come out here and
speak anymore on stage if this guy's
even gonna keep letting him in here and
he got so [__] pissed off he was
hilarious well you got scared he got
scared because he he's on a Twitter
space right yeah on his one cell phone
and then and he's got I I would imagine
that someone is is [__] stupid as Tom
Fenton has like six cell phones right
probably he's probably got a burner
phone to get his [__] steroids I mean
you know the guy's Juiced oh dude the
guys you're like a [__] just
juice oh my god well he's got scrawny
little legs so all he does is work is
everybody knows
from like the elbow up in any of his
photos and whenever he does he's always
here hold on you know what it's a
perfect Point hold on hold on so
basically the reason that Tom Finn ended
up blocking me was because I was on a
Twitter space I was on a cool space and
what happened was
um he was talking about
um
he was talking about that he was talking
I think when you when you brought this
up he was talking about the the felony
charges in New York right right yeah so
he was talking about that and I said
This Guy's in here this no-nonsense
lawyer this fake lawyer said something
like that this is the same guy who
emailed the White House and again
because nobody should forget this point
Tom fit and I was like this is the same
guy like nobody should no one should
believe anything or take what this guy
says seriously this guy emailed the
White House told the Trump
Administration before he told him on
Halloween October 31st 2020 he said in a
long letter that basically said you know
we can't believe any of the [__]
results out there so we should just
declare Victory there was an election in
I won and I brought it up and he's like
oh what is the rest of the letter I have
to say and I was like I don't have to
read the wrestle Letterman and I also
don't have it in front of me but you are
trying to argue this point of of you
should be respected as this legal mind
when you yourself are a job know nothing
want to be lawyer who's emailing the
White House I mean there's literal
documentation of you emailing the White
House and saying that you should just
declare Victory before they ever had the
actual November election right a week
before the election happened you're
emailing the White House saying guys you
should just announce that you won don't
[__] it [__] the results [__] the
results just announce that you won this
is also the same guy who cannot accept
the outcome of the election same with
Seb Gorka right you know love you Seb
but you gotta come to reality you cannot
accept the actual grounded real factual
reality that we all live in these guys
live in some [__] alternate
space could time continuum they're
[__] in somewhere else
unable to accept what's happening before
them
despite the fact that there are facts
right
and then we find out today so it was
after that point I think he blocked me
but it was after it was after that point
right
that we fast forward to because you've
been on the space a few more times and
continue to be talking about how oh
these doc this document case isn't real
and it's all this and it's all that yeah
I think the last the last experience
that I had uh in a space that he was in
where I was in there with him yeah was
he was talking about him and Doc oh my
God doc he's even [__] worse that
guy's supposedly a lawyer and he's even
worse than but they were talking about
how Donald Trump he gets to have these
documents no matter what they're his
because he used the presidential records
act to make them his I'm like that's not
what the presidential records act does
yeah but I mean you can't expect them to
to know any of that right well I mean
what the the problem is is that it again
it's cognitive dissonance right yeah and
and Donald Trump I believe and don't
expect them to to Define that for you no
well well I mean they may have to go
look it up but they wouldn't do that
because they're [__] boneheads but
here's the thing is that
I believe that the reason why Tom Fenton
has Donald Trump's ear is because Tom
Fenton tells Donald Trump what he wants
to hear that's why that's what he like
Donald Trump's like oh he goes to
Corcoran and corcoran's like look
let's just [__] give them their [__]
back let's work a deal where the deal it
was it was kais was it case Oh I thought
it was Corker anyways no price is a
better attorney than Corcoran right
price is the actual he's the remember
kais is the attorney that said in order
for me to work for you I've got a three
million dollars up front right so okay
so I got it right back I got it wrong so
kais is the one who was like look let's
go [__] work a deal they're gonna
work a deal you're a former president
they want their [__] back you gotta
sorry man well and not only that I
believe that kais's case probably would
have been look there's a lot of boxes
there's a lot of [__] that Nara is
probably willing to spend money to help
us go through this [__] to figure out
what is yours and what is theirs right
and we can work a deal and no one will
know any different it'll just be on
President Trump inadvertently packed
this stuff and nara's the one who have
facilitated it they went to the [__] and
they got their stuff president Trump has
his and they could have done that last
year but he said no [__] you because Tom
Finn's like no [__] damn that's your
[__] which is it's not it's not and and
the reason why it's not is because of
the presidential presidential election
right that's why it's not his because
the presidential presidential records
act lays out in specific detail what is
and what isn't a personal item from for
the president
and that's why the sock drawer they
bring up the sack drawer case because it
sounds all it sounds like you had a
classified document in Stockton no they
were diary recordings for a book that he
was going to write yeah it was
recordings for his ghost writer you
[__] boneheads and they declared that
it was a personal diary what what is
this picture here okay so this this
photo is an example of Tom fitton as the
Judicial Watch group
if if I did this like the whole show
yeah I just well it's not even it's not
only that but he's just like what you're
just like sitting there and he's like oh
let me just [__] look at the face look
at those face remember to show you some
[__] triceps do you remember do you
remember
this reminds me of the vengeance
you think a guy with triceps like this
would lie to you about the log come on
man this reminds me of the video that
we've watched the Ben Shapiro when he
does like his little stupid uh you know
gun show
he's like okay okay time for the gun
show and it's like dude
yeah it's ridiculous
outfits at different points
wait a second I see this going awry
because I do ask me anything now ask me
anything is I'll answer anything I won't
do requests like that that's not I just
want to be clear that the audience that
anybody out there on my patreon I don't
I don't take requests to do things I'll
answer a question but I'm not gonna do
the gun show I see that going south but
this is Tom Ben this is really him this
is not a doctorate image real dude this
guy this guy is um do you see how he has
this sleeve that he's got flexed here
he's got it this one's this one's like
not it's pulled down right on the right
yeah he's like sitting on an angle you
know what this is this reminds me of
when you had like uh grade school photos
right and so when they're taking the
photo instead of like taking it straight
on there's a reason right you want to
angle right you want to look this way
because you want the light a certain way
it feels awkward when you're doing it
like as a kid you're like ah and then
you know boom boom when you take the
photo you're like oh that photo looks
great awesome right because they they
technically know what they're doing with
lighting and [__] yeah this guy Tom Finn
this [__] legal cuck here decided and
he was like I'm gonna I'm just gonna
pose while I I'm gonna use the backdrop
of my fake Legal Group and [__] show
you that try [__]
one stop [__] this stop using the
steroid use because it seems like it's
really he's got he's definitely on gear
right he's definitely on gear there's no
way I also think that if you look at
everybody
there are two things I noticed one Tom
Finn is embarrassed by his teeth okay oh
really yeah and I well I say that
because I gotta find it I gotta here I
got a photo of it all right hold on okay
well let's bring that up Melanie says
here on Facebook sure sure Tony you'll
do things I mean you know what if you
paid me enough money I
probably wouldn't I'm not I'm not gonna
lie I'm not gonna lie I am a [__] look
man okay
so this is this is Thompson oh wow yeah
uh short Gap
look like the teeth have been worn down
now if I look over time I think what
I've noticed is that the teeth are a
little bit more so he's got like veneers
or something no no no no veneers veneers
would be [__] white veneers would be
even in larger like none so what has he
done so so is he doing like the clear
mouth guard things like uh
like he's a non-lawyer no the Gap the
Gap stays baby okay
so you can still kick a field goal here
you can still you know it's good and
that's a joke from uh um Professor yeah
he's like you're the gap between your
teeth is so big you can kick a field
goal through it
um
but no so what I've what I've seen is uh
you know I see somebody like ooh too
much method they do kind of look they do
you kind of have that messy look if you
think that you can just email and say oh
these documents are yours or you should
keep them and that you can fight the doj
you might okay or you might be on meth
to listen to a guy like this I mean
you're you know you're like look at it
look at that guy what the [__] that's
[__] nasty bro oh [__] [__] [__]
dude it's good well you look at the seat
like it looks like they've been worn
down right they've been like ugh but
he's but he's embarrassed by this you
know because it would be one thing if he
wasn't embarrassed by this right because
if you look at other photos right he
goes back and he doesn't smile right or
he does smile and he won't show his
teeth right you'll see him uh in in
various different ways that when he's on
you know like uh like this
then
yeah kind of like that yeah yeah he has
moments like that like I there's a joke
I have in my what was that which
basically I and I've I've said it to you
and I was like Spot the Difference
between these two photos because I'm
pretty sure I thought
Tom Finn was [__] thwomp from Mario
the dude is really especially when he
shows his teeth dude it's nasty so what
I yeah I think when you showed me that
in Texas I think I was drunk and I was
like I thought it was him I thought that
was
he is dude
but but you know what we should do on
our patreons we should we should do
screenshots of our text messages and
show them to our patrons sometimes oh
yeah yeah it's like an inside he's gotta
blur out the dicks yeah right right
right uh Gabe's always sending me this
guy with the last name Sanchez every
time it said broke his dick
but what I'll say is what I'll say is
Tom fit in here uh I think I think his
teeth have gotten more worn down right
which make them look weirder because of
that Gap there so is that more meth or
is it it might be I think it's I think
part of his like stack his like gear
that he takes is meth oh okay I wouldn't
be surprised classified documents
like that's what so you think he's like
he's like Tess human growth hormone mess
yeah I think honestly like so like she's
using test tests and human growth on his
days off but his days on he's like
[__] messing it up like oh yeah
[__] who reverse curls [__] this
constitution
uh yeah I I guarantee I I okay you know
what I would hate to have to go to his
gym oh God oh my God I I want to put I
want to put this down ready
I would put a hundred bucks down on the
fact that Tom fitton is a [__] mouth
breather and when he eats he's like
I guarantee Town fitness like that the
guy has the intelligence of a [__]
neanderthal the guy looks like he's a
neanderthal like he's One Step removed
from a neanderthal like he looks like he
was the missing link to how we got to
humans and we look back and go oh man
we've be we've come a very long way
right that is even Encino Man would look
at Tom Finn and go oh man I'm more
advanced than you dude like this is the
this is the [__] legal cuck that we
have to deal with but thankfully
thankfully this legal cuck is the reason
Donald Trump got to where he is right
now in this legal oh yeah baby and I
hope he keeps going that's what I told
that's why Tom hates me because that's
what I told him the first time I ever
got to talk to Tom
in a space and I think I haven't talked
to him since because he doesn't [__]
like me but and he probably leaves as
soon as he sees me in the space like
when I come into space
every time I go into space I start
laughing especially when Doc is talking
Doc's like oh I see you hi Tony like I'm
not doing it for you dumb [__] I'm
laughing at all of you and the thing I
told Tom the first time was keep going
man him and said that's why I remember
that I came in later that day going
don't stop man you're gonna convince
large swaths of America that Donald
Trump is a stupid [__] when
they're listening to people like you
they're they're not gonna believe your
horseshit you guys you're not even
you're not even looking in the mirror to
say your arguments first and this was
about the uh again the
the felony the 34 felonies in New York
on business fraud because they were like
this is going to destroy the country but
it's gonna guarantee that Donald Trump's
a president I'm like you gotta pick one
either that or you're saying that Donald
Trump being president would destroy our
country like which is it
um speaking of destroying a country and
the guy with the last name sanjays
there's a remix to the song that we
played the other day I don't know how
many of the audience caught and there
was an Easter egg the other day on the
episode I played the song After the
credits there was like I don't know
there's like there's about 1200 people
still on the broadcast I'm like ah [__]
the credit server I'm gonna play that
song yeah yeah at the end to see how
many people notice to see how many
people actually are sticking around to
the very [__] Bitter End and there's
a lot of people at The Bitter End
because a lot of people like oh my God
this song is playing but here's a remix
that small ranch so small rats thanks
for the original but thank you so much
for the remix and the reason why the
remix is so important here at Gabe
Sanchez the reason why it's breaking
news really honestly is because it has
Seb in it Seb is that making a feature
on the remix
seven if you're watching man thanks
thanks for all the contributions here to
the remix of the guy with the last name
Sanchez
[Music]
snake
now I get to talk do it stop stop stop
stop no no no no no no no no no no no no
I'll probably get to talk
and I'm a [__] cook
ah thank you smart that's fantastic I
love I love how you put Seb in there
love you Seb level sub oh my God Seb
Gorka what up you're right he is a cuck
dude the guy is so I mean if you go
through that that because I had to find
where where Seb was on and I I sent I
had I had I sent it over to our mods
right and they sent it over to small rat
and small red [__] cook that dude
that [__] in the kitchen could have made
it any better I thought I was like
there's no way the remix it can't be as
good as the original I don't know man
that's pretty good clear you cleared the
bar you totally cleared the bar for sure
I'm gonna point something out here yeah
we have the best [__] audience in the
world oh so great there is not a [__]
political show out there political show
that is political that talks about
political narratives talks about
political stories where you're gonna get
the audience making a [__]
a music a [__]
uh a beat and a tune with uh [__] a
costume of Taco Bell hot sauce with Seb
Gorka in a Twitter space you're just not
gonna [__] find it folks I mean if
you're looking for it you found it
you're here so don't forget to subscribe
like right [__] now like if you're
not subscribed already what the hell is
wrong with you we just showed you one of
the best pieces of content that can
absolutely be produced from just any old
conversation with Seb Gorka right yeah I
mean this is right right
how much [__] better do you get than
that you just don't get any better but
you know if you're still if you're still
um you know Tethered to the facts and
you know you you want to not participate
in the cognitive dissonance of manga but
you're looking
um for a way to really decouple yourself
from reality I'm looking for it here I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm setting this up so I can
find this uh this new commercial that I
found okay um you might you might want
to consider especially if you have Trump
arraignment syndrome oh yeah I hear that
I hear that's a great thing these days I
found a commercial I found a product
gave Sanchez oh word yeah this is uh
this is a fantastic product I think I
think this is going to be really huge
this is really going to kick off
um throughout the country especially
with moglodytes these uh these these
[__] cult members right this is going
to be great they've got a new
prescription now it's not FDA approved
okay oh yeah well the only reason why
they don't FDA approved because they
know if they do FDA Brew there's no way
these [__] are going to take it
they'd be like what
is this 8G and [__] you got to do small
Pharma not big Pharma exactly yeah
exactly well it's it's it's actually big
Pharma just relabeling and stuff because
they don't know the [__] difference
right they're boneheads they're
boneheads it's Trump arraignment
syndrome but here's the commercial that
I found
um on this I think the project project
product is called tropical I believe
okay
are you suffering from Trump arraignment
syndrome do you find it hard to accept
that your favorite former president
might have committed a few uh oopsies
well worry no more introducing trumpet
all the only medication specially
designed for Mac Republicans who just
can't accept that Trump is a criminal
with Trump at all you'll experience a
complete denial of reality right when
you need it the most trumpet all
specifically targets areas of your brain
so that you'll be convinced it was all a
deep state conspiracy a Witch Hunt or
maybe just a huge misunderstanding
thanks to Trump at all I don't have to
read any of those dumb indictments I
mean who needs the truth when you've got
a pill trumpet all is not responsible
for any side effects such as strained
relationships ignoring facts losing
touch with reality or an uncontrollable
sexual attraction to your own daughter
but hey that's a small price to pay for
your unwavering devotion so if you're
tired of those pesky legal proceedings
and those annoying voices that tell you
truth matters look no further Trump at
all is here to help Trump at all making
denial great again warning trumpet owl
is unapproved by reality please consult
the same person before use so I don't
know how much is Trump at all is but I
want to go back to show you something uh
the audience something here
um this here apparently one of the uh
active ingredients in this is horny goat
weed um that's uh that's something else
the horny goat weed orange the
hydroxychloroquine is also that's a
favorite of theirs yeah I mean
hydroxychloroquine apparently will cure
anything
it's uh yeah
it's a they say it does a lot you you
can't confuse it with the the uh fish
like water cleaner yeah oh okay yeah
it's a little different then yeah I
think that's like
hydrochloride rocks
I don't know it's hydrochloroquine not
hydroxychlorine right now the difference
right that was the one that sent those
two people in Florida to the emergency
room right I why I'm not real sure but I
wanna I wanna show you something else uh
I don't know if you recognize this guy
but this guy uh Mario
Party Mario
it's a me a MAG
um
AGA Mario was on the show the other day
this was Tuesday so I don't know if
you're if you're doing the math but this
is fresh out of the can
um this commercial a lot of people are
saying that it was done
um you know is this a real picture did
you make this up with the Trump banners
behind or is that no that's a real photo
what the [__] are you [__] me that's
a that's a real photo that's a real
photo
uh but it it comes from
um
they're they're sold on Amazon I think
they're banners that are sold on Amazon
so when I looked up like I was looking
up like Trump house or like Trump uh
trumpy art or something like that there
used to be a there used to be a person
that lived around the corner that had a
truck a huge Trump Banner that said no
more [__] right I was like oh that's
funny
uh so I used it wait wait are you for
Trump or against Trump because it was
for Trump because across the street was
a Biden Harris flag on the building so
they were doing oh I see so they so they
so they obviously need Trump at all is
what you're saying yeah yeah and the
only time I ever used I took a photo
outside of their house because I was
like oh I need a backdrop to set up like
there's a family inside a trump house
and the only conversation that these
Trump people would have uh was Trump
2020 and they used it so but it was all
it was all different emphasis and
meaning like it was like you know Trump
2020. trump 2020 and then they're at the
dinner room 10 they're like Trump 20 20.
2020. uh yeah it's a Amy here on YouTube
uh has a comment she says yes horny goat
weed is a real herb horny quote unquote
yeah doesn't mean what you think it
means can you go back to the ingredients
there's another one in there too oh
really all right yeah okay yeah sure
I'll go back did I look at the other one
yeah which is
flew I forget how to pronounce this uh
don't count on me yeah yeah no I I get
it I get it [__] I can't I I only speak
hillbilly I don't I can't [__] are
you [__] me
flu nitrogen recipes yeah it's you know
what it is what is it it's a rofanol
it's uh roofies yeah benzos like you're
trying to take [__] so it's that's so
I put it in there it's like oh it's a
drug they probably get high on then they
take horny goat weed thinking it's
something sexual you know and then
hydrochloroquine they take as a way to
oh you oh I see what you did I see what
you did so you think Maga would believe
that horny goat weed would make you
horny uh-huh yeah not that it's because
there are there are what and it's horny
means like horns not like yeah yeah yeah
not like I want to [__] something but oh
yeah they're not gonna turn you into
like the devil you know or something
like that well I mean we don't want to
confuse them right but I I figured if I
was gonna put together you know
um um a little bit and like for anyone
so for anyone who who sees this MJ of
course of course MJ would say Ben says
why not I don't think they make benzos
anymore right but they were fun
um I don't know if you find a stash
somewhere let us know maybe right I mean
in uh in Wolf of Wall Street right he
gets a bunch of expired benches
Quaaludes
uh
uh that's whatever's like oh they don't
make whales anymore
um but no so like that's a damn shame
isn't it I mean they don't make Quaalude
I'm sure somebody's trying to make him
out of their [__] rat Shacks I know
I'm just saying that you know but anyway
I will say I enjoy putting in little
Easter eggs right for people
John says on YouTube
horn woke weed I mean if there's such a
thing I feel like I couldn't really put
one ink in there because then they would
they would they would sneak it out and
be like oh no I'm not gonna take this
trouble hey
put a horny woke weed in there you they
totally would have known this was yeah
yeah I mean if I put a long list of
ingredients or a hid woke within a word
right so they have to pronounce it but
yeah maybe it'll work but I like to do a
lot of these little like Easter eggs so
when I saw people were noticing you know
what the
um
what what the what the ingredients were
I was very happy right there's I always
I always like to you know little details
here and there where I put in
uh an Easter egg where I'm like ah if
somebody finds it great if they don't
it's whatever right whether it's a joke
or it's a it's a photo or it's a little
tiny line somewhere right
I try to I try to add those things in
and those are some things that you get
if you join my patreon yeah because
there's a few things in there from the
audience I believe yeah well they're one
thing one thing is from jointly oh so I
I was I and here's here's the timeline
of events I was coming back from FedEx
and I was texting you at FedEx to be
like oh should I call it yeah cause he
was he was trying he had two different
names and I was like okay
I can see him but I'm like how are you
gonna Sam into the recorder so I can
hear it so I can hear how you're gonna
say it in the commercial yeah and the
other one looked better what was the
other one
trumpet look like Tylenol yeah but Trump
a tall sounded better yeah yeah so I was
like all right I'm gonna make this
change and I'm like and I was like well
they're probably they're we're gonna say
it a lot we're gonna say Trump at all a
lot so I was like go with the sound then
the look yeah right because we're gonna
say it a lot Trump at all yeah yeah
Trump at all Trump at all Trump at all
but so he went with that
um but there was what was the one line
because as soon as you sent me the video
the one line I was like I pulled it out
and I I texted you the one line I'm like
that's hilarious oh yeah so so the line
when you when in the video it's it's
goes through the symptoms right of like
right me staggering through you know I
just wanna well I'll tell you that story
in a second because that happened the
day I came on to the show on Tuesday
so I uh the line was an unusual or
uncontrollable attraction an
uncontrollable sexual attraction to your
own daughter right and the reason in the
way that it comes out is because on on
Monday night I was at FedEx I took a
photo and shared it to everyone all of
my patreon members to say like hey I've
got this video this commercial coming
out and I think you guys are gonna
really like this
and it was just the logo and it was the
printed out sheets because I had I
remade the label right because
unbeknownst to some people Gabe Sanchez
goes through great detail yeah he
actually makes the art to make the
[__] box and the bottle like it so
when you when you see it I don't have it
on my desk in front of me I think it's
out in the back but when you see it like
I remake the label for the pill bottle I
really like it would be like it would be
art that you could send to a company and
they could print an actual box now
you're mocking it up yeah yeah but I
take an existing you know right but
you're doing the art as if you're gonna
make a real make sure I get them
everything right I go and I print it I
you know I'm in the store double
checking because that unbeknownst to
some people they may not know that
you've done package design before yeah
so I have my expertise in uh in
packaging and design because that's yeah
just some of the stuff I do but anyway
I'm in the store and I take a photo and
I send it I share it on patreon and I
say hey guys expect this thing to come
out and people were you know chatting in
in the comments on on my patreon and
they said uh
um they were like oh this is gonna be so
funny I can't wait to see it blah blah
and joy Leaf one uh one of our one of
our our lovely lovely audience members
the people who's you know usually in the
chat um she's part of the patreon and
she said a list of things like orange
hairs tiny hands and the last line she
wrote was an uncontrollable sexual
attraction to your own daughter and I
was like oh I already have some stuff
about like
um reality ignoring facts but like this
is a funny like like a like a heightened
part of the joke so I was like oh I'm
definitely oh there we go joy leaves in
the chat here we go so shout out to Joy
Leaf because she was the one who
suggested I use or or just she I didn't
even suggest she just listened in the
comments as like what possible side
effects could be and I was like this is
such a funny last line I want to add on
to this that I think it would just be
beautiful and that was the first line
that Tony texted back to me laughing
hysterically when he sent me the video
what what was it yeah I want might have
been the full video it wasn't the full
video I sent you from the brain in in
part oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because because we had seen we had seen
the preview of the first part up to the
yeah but you hadn't had the that's right
so you sent me you sent me the latter
part of the of the video and this as
soon as I watched it the first thing I
text back do I leave was that line so
again I I just want to point this out
that our audience is the [__] best
audience because this shoe this show is
not just produced by me and Gabe it's
produced by you guys you guys are in the
chat you guys are talking to each other
you guys are engaging in your democracy
you're engaging in laughter and fun
cathartic release and strategic outrage
whether it be on YouTube whether it's on
the up wires YouTube channel whether
it's on Facebook whether it's on Twitch
you guys it's a real audience here and
and we want to grow the show and we are
I mean today we've had over 2 000 people
watching live which is awesome it's
awesome that that's uh we're growing
we're growing yeah just uh three or four
months ago we were getting 12 to 1400
now we're getting 1800 to 2 000 people
watching live every single day and we're
gonna grow and grow and grow and the
reason why is because we do fun stuff
like this and because you guys are a
part of the show exactly that's why
that's why I believe that that this show
is going to be successful is because we
try to make you part of the show you are
part of the show you're part of the
[__] fam and we try to bring you in
and you guys are so brilliant you're so
funny that's why we like to bring up
comments sometimes we least we waste a
lot of air time laughing with you guys
be but it's because you're so funny
because because we love your humor we
love it you know some of these things
that you comment on patreon
well I mean it's way in it's Miss love
seek's birthday today happy birthday to
Mr happy birthday happy birthday to her
but she's the reason why we have the
[__] Pride The Pride merch here let
me show you the art that Gabe came up
with she suggested in the chat and it
rang up and there was tons of comments
that yes we should do that
um and here's the here's the result that
Gabe uh designed for the pride [__]
thing and it's because of Miss lovesick
so happy birthday and thank you for
giving us the idea of this it's
fantastic everyone's loving it this is
um by far the most popular item in our
store right now so you go to stored I
think Tony michaels.com and check it out
but it's Miss loveseat that helped us
with that idea but I do want to point
out one comment here uh it's a it's an
important question uh about Trump at all
and I believe that if it's not going to
be FDA approved that the the customers
who buy this trumpets all need to know
this uh this is a question from Jack and
maybe you
and you know what I believe that you can
take actually hold on let me let me go
get let me go get it and I'll bring it
over okay okay okay go ahead and go
ahead and go go grab it and then we can
um we can um we can do that but you guys
are you're the best audience in the
world you truly are we we love every
single wannabe we love the haters too
here you guys know that um we we welcome
the people who love us and people who
love to hate us I mean that's the whole
idea is we're engaging in our democracy
right but again you're not gonna find a
show like this
you're not gonna find it out there
anywhere that's doing it like we do it
right I mean yeah there's some that are
similar but no one's gonna do it like we
do it and we're going to continue to do
it uh he's he's back here let's see you
know what what do you got there you're
gonna have to unmute you muted remember
you muted you muted all right well I
didn't want people to hear me open the
door and stuff you know okay well I had
I had you I had you on mute so I got
trumpet all right show in the Box show
on the box turn this up I tried one on
this side but it was two two I was too
close oh okay I I did a new one so okay
so you cut a new one yeah but look at
that look at that that looks like that's
a real if I had if I had more time I
would have you know sized it even closer
but this is right so is it actually a
Tylenol box no no it's an Excedrin box
oh okay it's Excedrin so I needed some
Excedrin because I was like God damn
Trump is giving me so many headaches
right now so then right then you got the
trumpet all the the actual bottle
so there's actually yeah there's actual
trumpet on here man
so did you did you make it too but you
didn't make it I didn't even open it yet
man I this is oh man you know oh man God
damn boom I just opened it up okay let's
see let's see what the trumpet tone
looks like yeah you can put this up your
ass
you could easily put this 100 100
I bet I bet there's a lot of them that
would stick it up their ass even if you
told them not to yeah oh 100 they're
eating [__] they were eating [__]
horse dewormer why wouldn't they stick
tropical up their ass look I got even
the ingredients listed on oh you can't
see it well anyway but on here it says
active ingredients in each capsule
purposes and then uh oh I actually had a
fourth ingredient on here too uh
propanol like uh like alcohol
that would go really well as a
suppository by the way and the purpose
is anxiety reliever oh okay and then
horny goat weed is happiness and the
flunazopram is a memory wiper oh
well all those you would need uh to be a
member of of Maga okay and I appreciate
uh well we're gonna be I'm sure I'm sure
that commercial is going to make it it's
yeah it drowns on the show and and uh
you know and like I said some people
know I'm working on it uh I was I was
busy yesterday I was on set helping a
friend with a
uh with the commercial so I was not here
A real one an actual one yeah I can't
say the commercial because it's like
very hush-hush it's a it's a nice little
piece
um but I was uh
I was able dude I was on the field
yesterday at the Rose Bowl yeah [__]
awesome yeah you sent me a picture it
was totally empty it was just us it was
great it was we had the commercial
rented out the whole stadium oh [__]
that's yeah it was completely empty he
sent me he sent me a picture of the Rose
Bowl and I'm like what the [__] yeah
dude I took a video yesterday and it was
just from one run side
to the other yeah all it was empty seats
ever I was like no one here's the thing
no one will ever uh will ever be able to
say that they played
played uh soccer because I played I
played soccer later after we after we
wrapped and also was able to drink I
drank beer on the state and and the
grass now here's the question
was it a queer beer because that it was
it you know what it was what was it it
was Modelo
one of The Producers was like hey can
you go grab some beer and some ice right
so we can all just like hang out and I
was like yeah sure so and our son went
out and you know I was like ah do I want
that gay ass Bud Light and I was like no
yeah I want that um
that's owned by the company you know so
that's hilarious so we had some Modelo
and then uh we just hung out and [__]
we had a couple soccer balls and we're
just like playing a quick game teacher's
asking a very important question here
you were at the Rose Bowl but were you
smoking no I didn't smoke different
flowers different flower you know
[__] you missed the opportunity
boom man is that the first time you've
been to the Rose Bowl no I'd actually
been to the Rose Bowl once before I went
there there's a flea market that happens
at the Rose Bowl oh it's awesome anyone
here or is it like uh I think it's every
month oh okay so they have like it's
like an ongoing thing once a month yeah
yeah but yesterday they were also
setting up outside of the outside in the
parking lot area they were set up or
there's some like Lego like convention
happening and there were some crazy
labors like a whole [__] there was a
tiger that was built out of Legos they
had huge Lego games and stuff they were
setting up for it's actually pretty cool
but yeah I was there and it was a ton of
fun and I was like I never will be able
to experience this again so it was cool
I you know did that for the day so that
that's that's exciting and we missed
yesterday but Texas Paul stepped in for
you hit the second half oh yeah so he
threw to us and then in the chat he's uh
or he texted he's like [__] it he's like
hey man I noticed I heard that Gabe's
not gonna come on today I I I'll uh I'll
come fill in I'm like yeah sure why not
well
tripod tripod Paul tripod Paul on
Wednesday yeah uh what are uh what are
uh Edward over here who by the way
All-Star if people don't know that
Edward does a great job behind the
scenes he helps us out on the other side
now
um because there's just so much [__]
coming at us from all sides of news and
he's a great he's a great filter so
thank you was that was 18 no no I was uh
uh my actually my friend was the ad on
the commercial and I was a PA I was
there was a lot of things that happened
that had to happen
in the background for these surprise
moments to come out and so I was like
coordinating on two ends of the field
for these things to happen on cue so I
was more of a I was like a talent
coordinator uh PA so so wait yeah sweet
well we're we're glad that you got some
work in yesterday you got paid and you
had some fun at the Rose Bowl it's just
a shame that you didn't get the smokable
at the Rose Bowl yeah well you know
missed opportunities next time you'll
know next time you know I want to go
back um to something I was talking about
earlier yeah and uh when you came on it
was about this tweet from Nina Turner
now I always bash tyt here and if you're
if you're a snowflake in the audience
and you like tyt and you don't like when
I bash them well that's just stuff [__]
because I'm going to continue to do it
until they change their tune
um they're self-defeatist tune because
they're self-suppressing the vote like
morons
um and the pro-democracy Coalition they
are not a part of it until they stop
doing that that's my belief um but subie
brought up because as I bashed pod Saves
America too because pod Saves America
they're not in the same category as tyt
but they're [__] political elitist
and it they smell like political elitist
and people average working middle
Americans can smell what they're
stepping in which is political elitism
um and it pisses people off um the Sue
says pod saves America's target audience
is upper middle class right it's upper
middle class it's not well I mean
average working Americans I mean they're
educated guys who I mean did both of
them work on the Obama they both did yes
and I'm not disparaging no no no right
but whatever you do exactly right you
know they're coming in the way they
present their show the show that they
have right I mean it's just I think in
today's age there's a much better
political discourse than this idea that
they you can be talked down to and told
what the [__] to do like from this
stupid ass Nina Turner telling people
what they can uh
listen Nina listen
what you're saying is complete horseshit
here in the re here's the reason why
here's what she says
Nina Turner tweeted this yesterday she
says don't be mad at a third party run
Americans know we can do better than
Biden Trump or DeSantis now Nina if that
were the truth if that were the truth
then third party candidates would always
be up in the running and they never have
been they've never never ever ever ever
in the history of ever have been able to
compete with the two parties which only
tells you the fact that Americans
wouldn't choose a third party dummy
that's that's just you can see it in the
numbers the data doesn't lie you can run
your polls and do your stupid [__]
fake ass polls but the only data that
really matters is the [__] counting
of the ballots and the American people
don't want a third party to destroy our
democracy they just don't they don't I
mean there's a certain sect of America
that believes this bonehead injury that
Nina Turner is selling here but [__] her
listen if if you believe that a third
party can win in this country you're
delusional you are delusional we do not
live in a realm in a reality that a
third party has a chance of winning in a
two-party democracy Now the problem that
our democracy actually has right now is
we don't even have two parties that are
interested in democracy so if Nina
Turner is suggesting
you know I would maybe take her
seriously
if she was suggesting that
what we should do is have a different
party than the Republican party then
maybe I'd start to take you seriously
right right I might take you seriously
that might be fair but that's not what
you're suggesting what you're suggesting
is a third party that would have the
chance of destroying our democracy
because if there's enough of a pool of a
third party we know from the race in
1992 Ross Perot created this situation
where George H.W bush the incumbent
Republican president lost because Ross
Perot was in the race as a third party
Ross Perot did not have a chance of
winning but he definitely gave H.W bush
the incumbent the chance of losing yeah
this sounds familiar Nina hmm sounds
familiar sounds like just to me Nina
Tina wants Trump or DeSantis is what she
wants
I I do I do think that's what you're
saying I think it like you know when you
break it down to its most basic level
right I'm not saying
and Tony's insane that we can't have
these candidates right
however
if your candidate right your third party
candidate is going against an incumbent
President right who has been very
successful in passing legislation and
also handling a house that is controlled
by the opposing party right we saw it
with a debt limit deal the [__]
wrapped him up in a box and sent it back
to [__] Kevin McCarthy and said hey
happy birthday and it really was a
moment where just as an example right
and others that you saw last year
and the fact of how they're handling as
much of the the mess that they're trying
to clean up right because that's
typically how it happens Republicans cut
a bunch of stuff then years later a
bunch of those things end up [__]
blowing up in our face and then the
Democrats have to reinstate or come back
through and
um introduce new social programs or new
policies or or things to counteract
those things we saw with you know Bush
uh with uh with Trump deregulating
certain industries and certain things we
saw it with the train we saw with the
banking institution right there are
reasons we have these things in place in
in Republicans love to destroy
and if if we cannot use our power and
our influence as the Democratic party as
the incumbent party in power to fix
those things and you want to introduce a
third party into the mix and be like ah
well [__] it I'm feeling a little crazy
and you have such small support to do so
you're pulling those votes away from
someone who might be in the middle who
might otherwise be influenced to say oh
yeah Joe Biden actually did a few good
things and I want to see more good
things that come out of it right
when you have people like Nina Turner
and others do that
they're
siphoning off votes they're distracting
you from the real issues right because
what it ends up becoming is I'm a third
party candidate and nobody's listening
to me that's all the conversation is
right we saw it with [__] Joe
Jorgensen or whatever the [__] her name
was right here right right Joe Jorgensen
right you know I once saw someone
driving in the car and it was like give
it was like give a voice to Joe it was
on it was on like a back of a band it
was like give a voice a joke and I was
like Joe hasn't proposed a single
goddamn thing that makes any goddamn
sense okay she has no backing she has no
political influence other than pulling
votes away that might matter in in in
certain areas of the country but when
somebody like Nina Turner wants to
introduce a third party candidate show
me the [__] numbers
uh and Jill Stein uh as Steve says Jill
Stein is another one right all these
people are like I'm the green party I'm
the People's Party I'm this independent
party you're not doing anyone any good
how about we fix
what was broken with the party that is
fixing it right now
before you throw out like hey you know
what why don't you wait till 2028 have a
platform work on some stuff put your
name on a [__] bill co-sponsor it
show yourself that you actually have
stuff you have all these people who are
coming into uh to run as a third party
candidate who haven't actually held
office they're like I'm a nobody but I
can run the country and you're like what
are you doing why are you why are you
throwing yourself out there and why are
you throwing out and recommending a
candidate who has no experience and
couldn't [__] fight their way out of
a paperback when it came to legislation
Aaron Williamson I'm just saying dude
hey you know you know well yeah it just
doesn't make sense right uh here's a
couple comments
um and you know this goes back to the
tyt thing because Nina Turner is Wild on
tyt right they love you yeah Turner and
the reason why is because she says
stupid [__] like this because as
Jeopardy says here tyt hates Democrats
they're they're self-defeatist right
they're a it's
I think the term I used was
self-defeetest ultim self-defeatist
ultimatists right is the way because
there are other it's got to be this way
or no way at all right well that's not
way to look at [__] democracy because
then you just gave up and and Jeopardy I
I would I would add that I don't think
they hate Democrats they grift on hating
Democrats right like they grift on it
just like just just like everyone else
griffs on oan and Newsmax on hating
Democrats they're just they're just
singing the same song to a different
[__] audience right that's all
they're doing
um well they also they sing their song
to a group called Blue Maga right and
blue Maga is a group that are just as
bad at well a little bit less than you
know bad than than regular Maga but blue
Maga are so
so [__] like don't they call it blue
Anon blue Anon yeah blue and On's
another one they're so fixated right I
saw like people have called me in blue
and I'm like you're a [__] idiot
there was a you obviously you don't
listen to the single thing I say a quick
example of this is I have a friend who's
a content creator and she made a she
made a video you know making fun of um
of what's going on right now
specifically around uh around Trump and
these documents right and there was a
post about there's a video of this fake
it was an AI generated voice of Donald
Trump
talking out the transcript that had been
shared on CNN right right and it's
horrible it's horrible it's not good but
what I found was I found it you can tell
that it's fake yeah I saw a shared on
Tick Tock and Instagram and so like I
did a lot of research found the original
Creator I was like hey just so you know
people think this is real and it's being
used against the validity
and an authenticity authenticity of this
actual transcript it's going right into
the Playbook of this is fake we
shouldn't right because what the right
is saying is see it is AI right it is AI
because they use AI to dictate it what
was it this comment came up where you
know that my friend is kind of Creator
was like guys this is not real I'm
calling awarenesses like do not believe
this this is made up it's not real it's
fake and then they were like no no no
it's real he said this thing on tape but
not and it's like okay no the words are
real but this recording is not real it's
it's almost it's almost like that it's
17 recordings that they don't have they
can't say what's in them because they
don't exist right yeah give me the
[__] transcript man at least the idea
that these people want to argue that
there's uh 17 tapes that all of a sudden
just two recordings give me a [__]
break right
um so I wanna I wanna uh do a few more
comments here uh Texas Bossman and I um
he's talking about Nina Turner he says
she just wants clicks and that is true
but I also I also want to give you a a
sense of bossman's
um user because boss man
um you know you're definitely fitting
here at the [__] fam he says I can't
stand that hit your [__]
I mean I think my comment my comment
under the post
um that Chris made was [__] her I think
is what I said but he also says uh
because this Marion Williams is now to
the side now now they're supporting
Cornell West and he says boss man says
Cornell is a psychopath which Cornell
um he's he's certifiable for 100 and
he's got paper somewhere now I do want
to bring up a comment that John put on
here he said Bernie is backing Joe now
this goes to the heart of some of the
people on the left in our Coalition who
believed in democracy who were what we
would refer to as Bernie Bros or Bernie
or Bust or whatever the hell the the
phrasing would be of the move movement
from Bernie in 2016 and and on into the
primary in 2020.
but I want to tell you that there's a
new strategy that the Republican party
and Trump the Trump Camp is deploying
and I believe it's intentional and um
I've been doing some research on it as
far as historical context
um and what it means in the moment but
they're using a word and I said this
yesterday I teased it yesterday but
they're using a word called uniparty
This is what they're doing and you can
go to you can go to uh Twitter and
search it right now you just search
uniparty and you will see all the tweets
of these right-wing [__] scumbags
using this word uniparty and what
they're doing is Nina Turner Nina Turner
not only is um helping them helping
right Wingers because Nina Turner
whether she knows this or not she's
helping the Nazis when she tweets that
stupid [__] okay and the way she's doing
it is with this uniparty messaging and
this is very important because in the
1930s in Germany the idea was was to
make everyone else besides the things
that we believe our ideology the others
right if you're outside of our box
you're the others and you're our problem
you're the reason why we can't be
successful so we have to eliminate
everyone but us right that's the the
blinders on and what Nina Turner doesn't
know here when she is saying [__] like
this she is saying uni party uniparty
uni party whatever they want to
pronounce it but it's una party and what
she's doing is she's playing into this
messaging that the right wing and the
Trump Camp specifically and if you don't
think it's the Trump Camp just go
[__] look at these goddamn uh uh do
you remember uh
um the gas stove thing remember they
lost so so yesterday they
they [__]
they they won oh man and DC Drano what's
his real [__] name here let me I
don't know I don't know which I think I
think it was I just want to point out so
the the stove thing I think Edward
actually at one point maybe like last
month or something like that commented
that Gabe should make a commercial with
Sarah Mclaughlin uh music right uh like
that style with stoves and I just want
to say to Edward if you're in still in
the chat listening uh yes I am working
on that I do have to be careful because
the last time I did a Sarah Mclaughlin
uh parody of it was a it was a um
it was a video against Karen's maybe
I'll release it on YouTube did they
knock you on the music yeah they not
like months after like six months after
I released [__] Karen like adopt a
Karen video I got [__] uh marked down
and they're like nope we can't let you
use this where was this end I was on
Twitter I was on Twitter what it's on
Twitter oh what's Elon Twitter now you
can do anything you want over there I
know DC Drano now he deleted this tweet
he says
this was after they passed this gasto
[__] yesterday he says big this is huge
news the house passes Bill the same gas
definitely making this commercial now
honestly I might work on it today and he
deleted this tweet I can't believe this
this is big big
news uh as Dash debrisk you would say
big news
the Republicans finally figured out how
to do a passive bill on on the floor
that isn't going to go anywhere good
luck with your bill he thinks this is
big he deleted this tweet because he's
surprised
[Music]
it's just a huge misunderstanding
everyone it's just a huge
misunderstanding but this this is the
uni party stuff because
um DC Drano was really upset that they
didn't censure Adam Schiff okay now I
don't know if people were following the
atom shift censorship but what they were
doing besides
censuring him
as they were trying to find him 16
million dollars on the house floor so
here this is [__] crazy so what what
the Republicans in the house wanted to
do was to give the ability of the House
of Representatives to basically vote to
find one of their members 16 million
dollars
for doing their job right regardless of
how you feel about their job or like I
would love to [__] find Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren bobert into
Oblivion fine whatever you're right
but they wanted to make him give 16
million dollars of his own money right
which is [__] laughable that any that
the members of Congress would let this
go through do you know now this morning
they're talking about these rhinos and
this una party because again this rhino
uni party what they're doing is they're
saying these people these 20 Republicans
that voted with Democrats they're part
of the union party they're not
Republicans anymore they're not Maga so
they're part of you they're part of the
problem right do you notice this this
unit party starting to form around Trump
because all these people who want
DeSantis or someone else and are they're
just Democrats they're just Democrats
that they don't want Trump now here's
the thing
do you remember Thomas Massey do you
remember that guy oh yeah that guy loves
to grope guns yeah do you remember with
his family yeah Thomas Massey is no
[__] Rhino folks yeah yeah he's not a
[__] Rhino remember Thomas Massey
went to [__] MIT right not dumb he
just asked them guess who voted against
this Adam Schiff bill
yes Thomas Massey dad Thomas Massey and
the reason why he did is because Thomas
Massey and I I believe he released a
statement we might be able to find it
but Thomas Massey is like look if you
think the correct way of dealing with
Adam's shift is to to to be able to for
for the House of Representatives to vote
to take away 16 million dollars from a
member
you are out of your mind like that's
blatantly unconstitutional and it was it
was unconstitutional the on its face
it's unconstitutional they can't do that
they can't do that now we would love for
them to be able to do that but that's
not how it works now they were making
the argument that Nancy Pelosi was
Finding like Marjorie today the green
and Lauren bobert for breaking for
breaking house rules on security that's
different that's different than actually
I don't know doing your job as a
chairman or as a member of Congress in
and of itself which is really funny so
they're going to continue this [__]
about uh Adam Schiff but the best part
about about it is is that there's a huge
wedge to draw Mal and Thomas Massey is
now a Democrat apparently which he's not
welcome to be a Democrat if you want to
know the honest truth no no thank you
you can keep him you can keep him Maga
but they hate him now because he's part
of what they're calling
um I think it's the what what is it the
something 20. he's calling it something
let me look it up 20. I have a I don't
I'm trying to track down when or what
time this uh
when this was hold on let me look you
talking about the vote no there's a
there's a video with Rudy Giuliani I'm
just trying to figure out when this was
oh oh is there something breaking on no
I don't know if it's breaking I got
that's what I'm trying to figure out
what the time time is on this oh it's
the coward the coward 20 is what he's
calling them the calories
they always have the stupidest names the
coward 20 you couldn't come up with
something better than that so okay I
guess it's kind of breaking news I'm
trying to figure out if this was today
oh and by the way this this DC Drano his
name is Rogan Rogan Rogan Rogaine
r-o-g-a-n
Rogan Rogan Rogaine I'm gonna call him
Rogaine I don't give a [__] I'm calling
him Rogaine
um is this the link to the Giuliani
thing yeah yeah
so okay I'm trying to again I'm trying
to track this down on Newsmax to see
when this was
but uh but wouldn't you know it looks
like they lost something again Tony oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait this has
to do with these recordings right
no this is okay so this is the Biden
stuff okay so so so for folks out there
don't know the Republicans made up a
bunch of horseshit the other night
before Trump got arraigned so here's
what happened the indictment comes down
the Republicans lay out a plan to make
sure to to to flood the news on
right-wing news media because they have
to flood the news on right-wing news
media they can't they can't control
mainstream news but they definitely
control right right wing media like Fox
and all that [__] to you know they're
really [__] uh give the trumpet all
effect to all the mangas watching uh
their right-wing [__] so what they did
was is they took this 1023 which is an
interview Forum from an FBI agent that
God knows who the [__] this person was
telling these lies but this person said
to this FBI agent that there were 17
recordings 15 of them were 100 Biden one
of them are two of them were with Joe
Biden and barisma which they don't exist
they don't exist they just said to the
FBI agent that they have them there was
never any Gathering of evidence this was
from sorry this is from Saturday this is
Saturday Saturday yeah yeah this is this
weekend before Chuck Grassley went to
the floor is what you're saying because
Monday Monday night is when Chuck
Grassley went to the floor with this
stupid [__] line I expected what was
that on this this is [__] this is
hilarious okay so here is here is uh
Rudy Giuliani on Newsmax let's let's
listen to what he said about this uh Joe
Biden fake tape thing on a day in which
uh we find out that the bidens took a 10
million dollar bribe
from a Ukrainian my co-host which I
could have told you you know and did
tell them three years ago and uh they
followed up on none of the evidence I
gave them uh they were hoping the people
would disappear or die
uh it's extraordinary I I gave them one
witness that any investigator would uh
jump through hoops to go to gave him the
witness who is a woman who was the chief
accountant at this crooked company
barisma she was the wife of the former
owner who died under suspicious
circumstances uh and uh she was willing
to give up all of the offshore bank
accounts including the bidens okay so
here's the thing is that number one Rudy
Joe Biden was asking that this
prosecutor got it you got it yeah yeah I
thought I could catch the mute button
before I did it
so if anyone anyone who's listening if
you hear a lot
um so Rudy man here's the thing is that
um Joe Biden was actually
um you called barisma Cricket company
um Joe Biden was advocating for
the prosecutors to prosecute
that company that you say is corrupt
berezma that's that's actually what he
was trying to do was to try to prosecute
them but you know that's um
Edward says poor Gabe is allergic to
[__]
wherever this guy with the last name
sneeze kids
uh so whatever you do don't cut that
clip of him sneezing and tweeting it and
saying that he's allergic to [__] um
after the Rudy Giuliani you might do the
Rudy Giuliani and give it some content
yeah but is is that really Giuliani not
only is um not adhered to the facts here
maybe he's allergic to facts Rudy
Giuliani
um that he's not seeing the case clearly
but the other thing too is he's
admitting that he's the one he's the one
who gave this you know what we should do
because um
um and I got a message into Leb Parnes
because didn't let us say in a space
here recently that he had he was helping
Rudy collect this [__] yeah that was the
whole thing they were under the idea
they were under the belief that this
thing existed right and they were
working together
to that was the whole thing because he
was you know uh Lev was like I got on a
plane and I was supposed to meet Rudy he
was supposed to be on the plane with me
Rudy didn't show up and then what ended
up happening I got [__] arrested
right wasn't that the timeline
like there were different right I
thought it was like he got on the plane
and then that Rudy just happened to not
show up and didn't get arrested right
well I mean again again though that Lev
has claimed before I believe and again I
don't want to speak for him that's why
we should have him on right right is
that
um I believe because he he definitely
said that the hunter Biden laptop [__]
um they [__] drugged and bought
prostitutes for Hunter Biden to distract
him so that they could make a copy of
his laptop in a hotel room and I believe
that he's he has said that to some
degree some of this information this
fake ass [__] that that Chuck
Grassley said on the floor of the how or
the Senate excuse me on Monday
um is all [__] uh and it would and
it's because Rudy had it all made up and
then he siphoned it to the FBI right
um somehow some way so there's that uh
so it looks like Jesus Christ how many
people are gonna serve hundreds of years
for Trump I don't know I mean
I remember Tucker was like we have the
contents and it was sent to us in an
envelope and we lost that envelope you
know well here's 10. we got the witness
and that witness died
like the amount of no no no no no no no
no if you have that [__] release it
right you have the incriminating and I
said anyway I said it earlier this week
on the show I said if you have actual
evidence I think Tuesday I said it if
you have actual evidence the evidence
should be able to speak for itself you
shouldn't have to [__] fluff it up
and and prop it up and hype it up and be
like oh my God you won't believe these
things it I mean it's constant clickbait
you know it's [__] Jack prostate
should I release uh the receipts the
receipts not the tapes the receipts on
the Biden tapes on Tim cast tonight
never did hey guys should we really yeah
just [__] release the tapes already
do it well the reason why they can't
because they don't exist listen to Ted
Cruz here because you can't release
something that doesn't exist right
Senator Chuck Grassley went to the
senate floor and revealed that there are
17 tape recordings of phone calls
between this senior barisma executive 15
of those calls are with Hunter Biden two
of those calls are with Joe Biden
personally I asked the deputy director
of the FBI is it true that their 17
voice recorded calls they used to answer
I asked him does the FBI have those 17
recordings he refused to answer I asked
him will the FBI give those 17
recordings to the Senate Judiciary
Committee he refused to answer and I got
to say Eric
rights to see the FBI stonewalling and
protecting Joe Biden covering up
corruption in the White House no he's
just not going to capitulate to your lie
it doesn't exist if you have the
transcripts release the transcripts if
you have the video or the tape
recordings release the tape recordings
no one you know what I find what I find
hilarious and predictable is that
despite claiming they have 17 tapes and
this person held on to these tapes and
you know just because they were fearful
of their life and what type of
retaliation would happen and now and now
they believe that this is the right time
to come out you're going to tell me that
one it wouldn't have been released in
2020 if they had it all the way back
during barisma no [__] that [__] they do
not have the tapes they do not have
recordings they do not have transcripts
and the fact that they're so unwilling
right again yes release the Kraken on
Facebook says
[__] 100 and what did we find Rudy
Giuliani only have to [__] leaking
ink die off his head no actual
affidavits that were real and when
questioned about said affidavits or
actual evidence when it came to proving
there was voter fraud or malicious
um acts against the the November uh 2020
election Rudy Giuliani was like wow
they're all theories I mean he told
Rusty Bowers well we don't actually have
evidence even though they're like you
Jenna Ellis can you guys give us
something Cindy Powell can you give us
something like well funny story about
that it's all kind of like an idea in my
head right but I don't actually have
evidence and they're like so these
affidavits are just people talking about
that they think they saw something or
they never saw something like you hold
you hold up he'll he held up a stack of
papers in the same very in the very same
conference where he wiped his snot and
then wiped his forehead that is talking
about you're talking about uh Grandpa
farty mcsharty yeah and that's the same
time when Sydney Powell was like we're
gonna release the Kraken and everyone on
the right on [__] Clapper
parlor Facebook Instagram yeah give us
some cracking the Kraken smoking
cracking years later went out the Kraken
where's the [__] Kraken where you
have to pull up all these tapes these
these Zoom [__] uh tapes actual tapes
with Sydney Powell and and Rudy Giuliani
and the judge and the judge being like
can you prove this and he's like no
there was no fraud because because
Jordan couldn't lie in open court but
Ted Cruz can lie on Newsmax the funny
part is is Eric Eric bowling here
questions him and it's hilarious
the answer watch it is infuriating that
this politicized FBI believes they are
not accountable to anybody Senator say
that again if you will from from my
audience see massive audience are
watching you right now because
okay okay Eric I've listened to this
[__] box in the [__] space too the
other day I was in the space with him
he's so foolish but I did I did get him
on the record and I said Eric tell me
right now that if Donald Trump did use
these documents other than just keeping
mementos right that you'd be willing to
accept or like he was doing anything
malicious as well with his intent
will you right now on record state that
you will say that yes he should go to
jail and he's like oh yeah hands out no
throw away the key should go to jail
make sure you understand what Gabe
Sanchez yeah whoever this guy is with
the last name Sanchez in a Twitter space
he asked Eric here the the host of the
Newsmax show who is interviewing Ted
Cruz here you ask him that if these
allegations and these indictments and
this arraignment that happened on
Tuesday of Donald Trump if they turn out
to be real
that he will he will say yes he deserves
to go to jail and that he said yes he
would yeah so that's Eric but listen to
the question that Eric here asks
um the scummiest of the scum in the
Senate Ted Cruz I don't think I've heard
this and we've spent a lot of time there
are two I don't care about the 15 100
whatever there are two recordings from
with on one end of this phone line or
whatever wait for it wait for it Robin
o'biden and another is someone from
Barista yes because Biden is said
unequivocally time and time again I have
nothing to do with reason I know nothing
about it and you Chuck Grassley has
heard his voice on these recordings wait
so Grassley has not heard them what
Grassley has done now you can't hear
something that doesn't exist yeah he
can't hear yep so they're 15 they're a
hunter and two that were Joe and uh for
sure 100
okay you know what it depends on how you
define the word listen right you know I
mean
do you mean Mike do you mean like if
there's an audio tape and you have to
use your ears to hear an audio tape I
mean no that it that that it doesn't I
mean look look Grassley said that he
knows about so Grassley hasn't even
heard him no well see Grassley heard
from someone right that they they exist
right and it's like so again the
question should be or not even the
question the [__] demand because if I
was someone if I was someone on in the
Republican party and I had heard these
people talk about Joe Biden Hunter by me
and corrupt for years and they're like
oh man we finally got it this is it they
got
is that they're doing this on June 15th
it's j in middle of June in 2023 okay
they can't this will not this will not
play in this will not materialize this
is not materialized and all they're
gonna do is piss people off even [__]
more because they can't prosecute Joe
Biden or Hunter Biden on tapes that
don't exist they can't they can't I and
I know this morning they want to impeach
Joe Biden but the House of
Representatives can't even impeach him
on this because where what for what for
what because Chuck Grassley says
something on the senate floor get the
[__] out of here I have evidence right
if you don't shut the [__] up it's
really simple like if you have evidence
then you can prove that corrupt and if
Joe Biden or Hunter Biden did do
something corrupt and yes charge them
[__] indict them let's go for it yeah
I love this there's there's no reason
why if you if you have groundbreaking
bombshell undeniable evidence of these
two people doing something that was
corrupt then you should have no problem
to prove your case right and and that
goes the very same way that if Donald
Trump truly is innocent right truly did
nothing wrong truly was just keeping
these documents as mementos and
something just got lost up into
confusion and and and and there was
never this intent to withhold documents
or anything that was classified to give
back to the doj and the FBI and Nara
if it is actually shown that he's
innocent
then fine he's innocent I don't think
that he is but you know he's innocent
until proven guilty but Republicans are
unable to accept that aspect of Law and
Order
letting it play through and if his
defense can prove that they are or that
he is innocent
Kim here on YouTube says so they are
stupid yes 100 yes 100 yes there you
want to see someone else who's stupid
before we leave oh my God this is yeah
this is great I would imagine that if
Trump is taking uh non-lawyer advice
from a non-lawyer like Tom Fenton that
maybe Ron DeSantis is taking advice from
the same guy because this morning this
morning Rhonda Santos who is in wildly
uh down in the polls uh if if you want
to believe what Trump says he's he I
think he's in like a he's like
struggling to get out of the quicksand
well he is and but if you believe that
if you believe those polls which you
don't have to go very far to not have to
rely on polls just see how weird he is
and you understand that no one would
like this guy and that's probably why he
sucks and it sucks to suck but he sucks
so bad that this morning he's trying to
get Gavin Newsom to run against Joe
Biden Hey Ron I don't know what Thomas
told you but dude you're running in the
wrong race if you want to run against
Gavin Newsom possibly that would be 2028
dude you should have listened to me
months ago when I told you just say
you're gonna run in 2028 not 2024 you
dumb [__] you're in the wrong
year it's the wrong primary that primary
is going to happen in four years dude
but listen to Ron here this [__]
idiot putting fingers here listen to
this but what I would tell what I would
tell them is you know what would you
tell him what would you say [__]
footing around oh oh yeah
tens of people clap when he says [__]
foot [__] foot dude if you pudding
footing you're right that's true if if
you've listened to the Hannity interview
with Gavin Newsom you would know that
Gavin Newsom is not running for
president he's stumping for the current
president what interview did you watch
he literally said that again circles
around Kevin McCarthy right over and
over again and then and then uh Sean
he's like I wouldn't vote he's like yeah
yeah exactly dude Kevin McCarthy got
[__] played and owned by a guy that
everyone claims as senile and is living
in the basement right and then and then
when asked when when uh Sean Hannity
questions the economy and questions the
state of the country and what the things
that he's accomplished Gavin newsom's
like the chip act that you're you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna so you
don't like many things made in America
right like uh you you don't you don't
like American manufacturing you don't
want to to to challenge the industry
that lives in in Shenzhen China right
the CCP that is controlled by the CCP
it's [__] wild [__] now Ronda Santos
thinks because Gavin Newsom went on Fox
News he's running for president which
Gavin Newsom is not running for
president because Gavin Newsom knows he
knows unlike Nina Turner that stupid
[__]
Gavin Newsom knows that he uh no [__]
planet could he beat Joe Biden in 2024
he's just not going to do it in that
primary no [__] ways Gavin Newsom
going to beat him he won't because Joe
Biden is the um what's it called again
what's that word starts with an i
incumbent yep you stupid bastards okay
here is here's uh here's Rhonda Sandra
we'll finish this up because I think
it's beautiful here his little his
little uh tough guy routine
[Applause]
[Music]
and I said this I think it was in a
quote tweet uh the reason that Ron
DeSantis doesn't want
to actually debate gavinusum is because
for one he saw the interview with Sean
Hannity and was like right okay
got his ass kicked he's like oh well I
saw how the guy governs his his State
and he does pretty well and now that he
was able to have this like you know off
the cuff interview not knowing what the
questions were or you know thinking that
Johnny was like I'm gonna get you with
this one and now Governor's like shut
the [__] up man you don't know anything
just [__] knocks him down like I
understand is watching this one sees
that and you know under sees the
challenge and goes
um no I don't want that and then also
knowing that he has to potentially if he
stays in the race or even lasts long has
to go in against Donald Trump and prove
himself but time and time again Donald
Trump attacks Ron DeSantis Rhonda
Sanders goes
and doesn't do anything
and Ron DeSantis ends up looking like a
goddamn cook right because he is he is
he's putting fingers deep in cucking
around and so when you look at Gavin
Newsom and the way that he's able to
hold himself and be like yeah this is
[__] Uh Kevin McCarthy
is a is a toy to to uh to Joe Biden he
played him like a [__] fiddle
and so Ron DeSantis doesn't want to lose
against someone who isn't running
he doesn't want to go against Gavin
Newsom get owned by a sitting governor
of another state which the reason why
Gavin Newsom has picked Ron DeSantis as
his arch enemy is because Gavin Newsom
is going to run in 2020. yeah he is
going to run he's going to run folks
Gavin Newsom is going to be in the
primary and he's going to be a [__]
Contender I don't know if he'll win
that's a long ways off right I mean
there's a lot of [__] that could happen
politically between now and then but I
mean at this point is kind of the front
runner in 2028 already if you want to
say it that way and that's why Ron
DeSantis is pissed off is because the
word is is that Rhonda santis isn't
going to survive this race and he won't
make the 2028 race to even go against
gaviness
him as the enemy which is beautiful
all of this material right this this
dirt on on uh on Rhonda santis has been
drudged up right now it's there to be
like oh no no no no what was what was
there was a there was a bit of a there
was um the super the the PAC money right
wasn't there one where he had
transferred the money that he raised for
himself as Governor into the
presidential campaign and I think I
think drifted off everyone well and I
think I think uh Ty Ross uh Ty watches
the show each day and she's in the chat
sometimes I think Ty is actually uh
taking a look at that so yeah hopefully
we'll have something
um but it just goes to show you like the
guy is is an idiot and also is getting
owned on the left and on the right
and so now it's coming down to the point
of like this guy has no political future
because once he's done with this term
like oh he's [__] the only options
no he's not he can't win no no I'm
saying not saying he's going to but I'm
saying like what are the other options
right you could pull a Rick Scott right
and Governor to Senator yeah but but
Rick Scott didn't [__] get his ass
kicked by Donald Trump and Gavin Newsom
here's the thing here's the thing Ron
should have listened to me months ago he
should have gotten a race and just
resigned as governor and you should have
just got in the race and just started
pounding the [__] out of Donald Trump
just beating him the [__] up just every
single pass Rhonda santis personally get
in front of a microphone just kicking
his ass and Ron you would if stop
talking about wokeism if you would have
went against Trump you probably would
have you probably would have carried
water with a lot of [__] people out
there that don't identify as Democrats
but are on the pro-democracy side he
probably would have carried a lot of
water with them as opposed to trying to
say woke every moment you have a chance
to stay woke and you just would have
been the anti Donald Trump candidate on
the right you probably would have won
some some variation in a general
election but you've lost all that now
they know you're the stupid [__]
governor who can't stop saying woke and
you're the governor who can't even rebut
Gavin Newsom worth of [__] you know the
gavinism the libtard out in California
which is is I actually love that the
right totally underestimates Gavin
Newsom totally underestimates him
because folks that's probably going to
be our story story in 2028 is that they
totally underestimated Gavin news and
they thought he was some kind of [__]
hack they thought he was always just a
governor of California which is the
fifth largest economy in the [__]
world I mean it's basically its own
country to some degree when you're
talking about size of economies but the
thing is is that go for it keep doing
this just like keep taking your advice
from old Tom's small shirt I wear my
little sister's shirt Fenton fine great
my tricep makes me legally smart great
take the advice of that guy keep going
don't stop actually we'll get you a
backhoe if you want to dig a a good time
oh yeah yeah Barrel the entire
Republican party in let's do that I'll
do that will you do that I'll do that
every single weekday every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 but Civic on
YouTube Twitter and twitch do not forget
to subscribe to the YouTube channel
while you're here we were almost at 16
000. let's see where we're at here
oh man fifteen thousand nine hundred and
seventy we need Thirty people come on
there's 30 people in the chat that
aren't subscribed to the Tony Michaels
podcast to go to YouTube right now
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
also follow us on Twitter because
tonight is bonehead of the week where
you vote who decide who is the bone end
of the week tomorrow on Friday we break
it down for you and those are the two
places you can vote for bonehead yeah on
the YouTube Community Tab and on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod so don't forget to
follow us on Twitter and YouTube because
we'll do bone end of the week tomorrow
also so yeah go ahead oh as you say
Monday we have a special guest oh Monday
we have a special guest that's right uh
we got someone who's gonna break down
how you classified the Acumen how it
gets Declassified reclassified what it
what why classification matters because
this is complicated issues really
honestly I actually think we do need a
classification reform and maybe maybe
we'll answer this guests if he thinks so
too and what that was like when I when I
texted with him last night I was was
like Hey you know we'd love to have you
on you know he's he's previously helped
me on what was that
um for all those who don't know it it is
it's it's tell them who it is tell them
it's it's Fred Wellman yes it's Fred
Wellman so so Fred and I have previously
chatted back and forth when I worked on
my Jr Majewski uh what was that I just
need to know some specifics about
exactly some things that were mentioned
and he kind of broke it down and we
laughed and all that stuff and it was a
fun time and he was like oh man this is
a great great what was that that you did
uh on Jam rojewski way to [__] own
them so I texted him yesterday and I was
like Hey we'd love to have you on the
show to kind of break this down also
who who can pass up an opportunity to
[__] on Trump and he was like yeah I
would love to absolutely I would love to
and so he'll be on he'll be on the show
yes and we're also I've also rich people
are asking about Richard Ojeda uh major
o jet I've reached out to him we're
gonna have him on the show at some point
um so yeah we're gonna try to get all
these folks on the show
um it's important and I I've reached out
the lib Partners I actually reached out
to Ed uh kratzenstein today too because
Ed had a back and forth with uh Tom
Fenton in a space here recently about
some of this uh but Ed I think I believe
he's he's not available right now so
hopefully we'll get him on next week to
talk about that as well and I told him I
said hey this is this Tom fend and stuff
it's gonna man it's gonna it's gonna be
talkable for some amount of time here
yeah like this story is not going away
because
a lot of these stories that are coming
up now were discussed in 2022
right so there's like a there's a story
and I'll and I'll end up doing what was
that on this because this this this
aspect of of Tom fitton being the thing
that [__] brought is going to bring
uh Donald Trump down because he would
not listen to his lawyers is the
funniest thing and also the most Trump
thing ever it is right he's like no I
don't want to listen to my lawyers the
lawyers that I'm paying the guy that I
just dished out three million dollars
for for my [__] pack right that would
be smart that would be smart you hired
them for a reason you know what hey you
know what for Trump
Trump if you are so confident that Tom
fitton is right you should hire him as
your lawyer oh wait you can't because
he's not a [__] lawyer that's
hilarious Amanda points out here Queen
Rachel madikova is always a favorite
I've got contact with Rachel she's been
very busy this week
um so hopefully hopefully we'll get some
of these guests on next week
um we got a lot of people in the hopper
here to get on as guests uh it seems
like we do that like some weeks we don't
have very many guests and then some
weeks like every day yes yes yes
maybe next week will be a a week filled
with uh guest appearances so yeah I got
another one I got to talk to you about
after the show too oh great great great
so if and if you want to watch these
guest appearances next week you can
watch on YouTube you can watch on
Twitter you can download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google but if
you want to watch it live you can watch
it on Facebook too at the Tony Michaels
go to happy Tony Michaels if you still
have a Facebook account follow us you'll
also be able to watch them on the up
wire go to the upwire.com follow the
YouTube channel or just type in the up
wire when you go to YouTube you'll be
able to find the channel there make sure
sure you subscribe there as well you can
watch there and thank you to everyone
following us on Twitch it's free to
follow us on Twitch we're getting man
we're getting a ton of Subs over there
uh the people are are subbing with their
Prime account and they're resubbing with
their Prime account today uh Shadow
woman seven she's giving out Community
Subs over there holy moly it's like a
subscription waterfall
over on over on Twitch so thank you for
all the support on Twitch and you can
you can link your Prime account to your
Twitch account and give us that one free
subscription you get with Amazon gaming
we get a couple bucks each month it
doesn't cost you any extra if you have a
Prime account and the directions are at
are you just go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com you can
find that there bone of the week is
tomorrow it's Friday you vote you decide
go to the community tab on YouTube I
have a feeling someone's gonna be on
yeah I think it's I think I'm just
saying yeah right
um last week seemed rigged did you rig
the one last week it was fair I gave I
gave that person equal chance that is
true I get this person such a great
chance I put them in every single
category it's the only election that he
can claim this rig that he won right
that is true and this is true all right
well you find out who bone end of the
week is tomorrow after you vote on
Twitter and YouTube same time same place
tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
with the last name
[Music]
alone
thank you
everybody
now I get to talk